it's funny because you were not a
political guy until you got working with
this John story no he invited me to have
an opinion right don't I mean and no one
ever had that before like I was not
thinking about it you had come up with
an opinion yeah
but you and John as good as you were for
each other you did not socialize while
you were on The Daily Show you didn't
become the kind of friends that go over
to each of his home for dinner or go out
to the bar and have a drink blah blah
blah right now you do now but not but
well I mean listen it was easier for me
to understand what John's life was like
and what is going through once I was
doing a gig that was like his way out
with the lead guy you don't know what
the job is like that's one of the things
that I said to Jimmy and we talked about
when when we went out and had cocktails
you know that night he was fouling me
and found ice let's go and have
cocktails and because not many people
know what this gig is like Tran right
you know at the end of the day wouldn't
be nice to like go have a drink with
each other because there we can say like
can you [ __ ] believe what this gig is
like absolutely and that's what John and
I were able to do once I understood